[Music]
we are here at the restored dignity
foundation event such an awesome things
for bachelor nation to come together for
what means you want to come out um I
have just really appreciated you know
Ashley I get these things going and
reaches out to all of us and asked us if
we wouldn't be a part and I just think
she is so amazing because she has really
turned what the bachelors given her into
something that like gives back to so
many people well I love seeing you guys
all get together especially for a cause
like this but you just had some fun in
Tahoe with a nice group of people what
was that like for you to hang out with
then because you you dated Ben at one
point how are you guys well I mean you
know I feel like if you're like maybe
number three to or what it would be
different but being number five it's
like we were already kind of just
friends anyway I felt like I always got
friendship vibes from him but he's
honestly so so amazing I mean how do you
think he's doing Ben is very honest that
it's you know I think it's not been the
easiest time of his life but he still
speaks so highly of Lauren and you can
tell why he wants her happiness and I
think he wants to be happy and they're
both such great people I mean I can't
even tell you how much we talked about
The Bachelor it's almost embarrassing
and exact eyes and we'd be like let's
not talk about the bachelor anymore and
then the next few seconds to be like did
you see what Mike Fleiss way and what is
he like in person he's just funny quirky
he's so smart and you can just tell like
he knows exactly what he's doing cuz
even if people are saying I always crazy
what is he doing they're still talking
about him do people automatically assume
if you hang out with people from this
world that you're dating like people
think you and Dean are dating
yeah I've got no even my dad called me
the other day and he goes I got a call
from one of my buddies at work and he
and his daughters want to know if you're
dating a Dean and I'm like no we're not
dating
but it's fine I mean it listen if people
get excited about love and relationships
it's why they followed any of us in the
first place so I totally get it but I'm
very much single
and are you liking that yeah I'm happy
about it perfect you might have a
podcast in the works I do I do have a
podcast um so I basically it's gonna be
my Twitter but through podcast I always
feel so limited on Twitter because I
have something that I want to rant about
and there's so many good bachelor
podcasts that I thought I don't want to
be another one of those because I don't
they're really good and I feel like I'd
have a hard time competing with them so
I'm gonna be talking about my favorite
shows random topics from those shows or
just random topics in general and it's
called scrubbing in with Becca silly
little Grey's Anatomy reference their
how to throw that out